i'm just blown away bro this is the
first time in the history of the three
muslims
where we are legit starting off with an
actual disclaimer on a live stream
yeah yeah
but
as i've mentioned before anyone that is
not of age anyone that's young
this is not an issue that i want all
these kids to be watching i don't want
parent notes from you know moms and all
that after this
but
that being said
being a sensitive topic let's go on
so
a lot of people
that are on the internet and you should
you should know about this because it's
literally currently happening but those
that don't rami are you aware of what's
happening with drake
yeah so it's it's actually like you said
all over the internet and uh firstly
again viewer discretion is advised but
essentially what happened was um drake
took home a model and ended up sleeping
with her
and what he did was he took the condom
he put hot sauce in it so it would kill
the sperm and then he threw it away and
then what happened was the
model actually had this plan that she
would go and take
the uh sperm
from the condom
and impregnate herself
to essentially have drake's child so
that nine months she can probably go and
claim child support and like all this
stuff from him
um but
obviously because he filled it with hot
sauce or poha sauce and it killed the
sperm and ended up
you know hurting her so she screamed and
everything
and then the jig was up basically but
now as a result of that she's actually
suing drake
this is
subhanallah
listen bro
you are right i just want to quickly add
that
apparently they were just talking on
instagram right so
drake and this ig model they're just
talking on instagram
um
doing what they do and they wanted to
meet up so i believe they went out you
know for like dinner or whatever
and you know he took her back to
you know his room and it was very
consensual from every all the reports
including the reports from her because i
want you to understand that drake till
now has not addressed this issue he's
not even acknowledged it he's not even
given any type of credence this is just
from the
testimony of the the ig model
so it's very consensual there was no
nothing you know forced anything like
that
they did whatever
these two people would have done you
know behind closed doors but now
everyone knows about it
and you know once he finished he you
know disposed the condom like anyone
would
and he was just chilling and you know
she goes to the washroom he hears a
scream
he's probably thinking you know she hurt
herself or something happened you know
he went to go check
and
not to a surprise this is what she was
doing now i want to preface this by
saying that
i highly doubt this is the first time
drake did this
because he's probably not trying to have
a random woman
just get a millionaire baby daddy just
like that
whether or not this was her first time
doing it i don't know but whatever she
did this was clearly stupid because
forget about you know bacterial
vaginosis and all these other issues
that she could get with the hot sauce
she probably didn't know she was
probably way too caught up in just how
do i secure this bag that she didn't
even look down or wasn't even paying
attention to what she was actually
putting inside her
and this is what happened now this is
going you know completely viral because
everyone's like okay who's to blame
what's going on
and now she is suing him
so rami
based on what i told you so far all
right i just want to ask you a very
simple question
what's the first thing that comes to
mind when you hear all this
and i gave you both sides too i'm trying
to keep it very neutral very balanced
yeah well i mean honestly the first
thing that comes to mind is that islam
would have fixed all of this that's the
first thing i think about islam would
have prevented all of this stuff uh in
terms of the actual cases
themselves i guess as
the brother said she tried to catch a
case and
got one but not the one she wanted uh
yeah so basically what she committed was
something called sperm theft which is
basically when you try and coerce or
trick a man or
take whatever means necessary to
impregnate yourself with the man's sperm
beyond his you know
consent this could come in the form of
lying to him saying you're on the pill
or lying to him and and saying that
um you've undergone this i've heard some
poking holes bro
yeah poking holes in the condom as well
and this would be another example it's
actually not legally a crime as far as i
know
uh but it is wrong nonetheless uh when
you're talking about consent theory
there has to be room for this within
consent theory because drake obviously
did not consent and they both knew that
you know
a condom was being used in all of that
so
uh
yeah but how about you like when you
think of this what do you think of
before i address that i had a quick
question bro so you're saying this is
not currently like a crime
as far as i know legally sperm theft is
not considered a crime that's fine bro
yeah and it's messed up
it is messed up because bro think about
it like this forget all of the variables
aside before we get into slam and all
this
if a man
sleeps with a woman
and they want to use contraceptives they
both consensually agreed to doing the
act with the contraceptive
and now all of a sudden she wants that
so you know to me it's kind of dishonest
and unethical
but i'm not surprised because i'm sure
i'm sure these ig models and you know
i'm sure this is not the first time
she's she's thought of doing sperm theft
i don't know if it's the first time
she's done it definitely not the first
time um
yeah and yeah my first thought bro when
i when i heard about all this
is
as strange as this sounds i know this is
gonna sound super strange
but the world we live in with the with
the laws and the legal system and all
this
yeah she might there's a small chance
but she might actually win this
settlement
this is my first thought it was it's
such a strange thing to and i know i
know guys i wish the judge the
prosecutor whoever is dealing with this
case has the common sense that we all do
here
but there's still a chance that she
might actually win this settlement yeah
that's the strange thing about today's
time
yeah yeah 100 um this is the problem and
and people might be wondering why are we
even addressing such a thing and we're
not a drama news channel we're not just
here to report what's going on in the
news we're not freaking drama alert or
anything like that bro there's no
keemstar up here
but
yeah it is a big topic and people i
think the problem is people don't
realize how big of a topic it actually
is we're not just here to talk about
what happened and drake we don't care
about him in his life we don't care
about the ig model we don't care about
any of that we're here to talk about the
underlying issue
uh that there is to all of this
which is the law
of the west
their their philosophy their ideologies
their ways of life
and that they have a system that allows
for such a thing and that we have a
social system that allows for such a
thing why do people hate polygamy and
promote unlawful activity that's
honestly that is an amazing question
that is we'll get into that we'll get
into this question yes inshaallah we
will get there
um but we have to start at base one
which is what is the main issue the main
issue is that people are choosing a way
of life they're choosing laws they're
choosing a legal system in a social
system and certain morals and values
that does not come from someone who is
all-knowing and all wise it comes from
people with desires with the bias with
the lack of information this is who it's
coming from inevitably so are these
people really qualified to choose how we
should live life
wholesomely and how we should rule our
land and what laws we should have
clearly not because not even every
person in the society is going to agree
to that so what kind of you know
democracy do you really have if you're
leaving out a huge chunk of minority
uh
you know out of the equation to be able
to say what they believe what about the
other legal systems and different
religions that people you know attest to
having and want to have like muslims
having a lot we don't have shitty
accords in the west to be able to deal
with things like this according to islam
so
yeah i mean i want to pass the mic on so
i don't keep
let's start this at ground zero
so drake not being a muslim this ig
model not being a muslim all of this
aside
where this starts was something that
took place because this is where drake
is in his career now i want
anyone watching this they're like yeah i
wouldn't do this i wouldn't do that
listen we're not here trying to condone
what drake did or the ig model did
whatsoever but what we are saying is
anyone that hasn't made it to that level
in life in terms of dunya worldly
success because i it is it is not
reflective indicative of your your
success or value in terms of allah
whatsoever but in terms of dunya's
success fame money clout whatever you
want to call it
you don't know how you're going to act
once you get there
so this is not me trying to defend them
whatsoever but i'm saying it's easy to
say that when you haven't gotten to that
level
once you have gone to that level you
have unprecedented amounts of fitnah all
around you and it's very easy to slip
so
you know
i also want to address one thing too all
the people that are watching that
they're like oh there's
you know about mgtow right
yeah your men going their own way listen
listen to all the mektal people watching
this
this is proof bro that that mctell's not
it's nonsensical it makes no sense
because no matter where you are a man
and a woman they're always going to want
to get intimate this is this is reality
there's no and i don't care what you say
you know i don't need women or women
saying i don't need men
this is going to happen no matter what
all we are saying is things like this or
what's going to happen if you don't
follow a proper way of life
following a proper way of life
eliminates all of this from multiple
facets that we're going to get into
but just looking at what happened bro
this wouldn't have happened i agree with
you this is something completely this
it's kind of like these are the games
you got to play bro you got to regularly
get checked for hiv you got to regularly
you know put hot sauce you know the
frank's hot sauce slogan is literally i
put that on everything so they weren't
kidding bro
and and
look at what's happening bro
yes and you mentioned that you know when
someone gets to that level like you know
the fitna they they go through and
everything and obviously it's not you
know condoning what he did um i want to
give and again we don't care about drake
honestly we don't care about drake we
think him and everyone else should be a
muslim and you know live in the way that
god has instructed us to live so that we
don't commit atrocities and injustices
against ourselves and other people but
if you look to the quran
you see
yusuf
is narrated by allah
and by the prophet tell him that he was
the most you know basically the most
beautiful
uh man to exist
so the fitna that he had
was a lot worse i would say than what
drake had
and i'm i'm willing to say this because
he was like a very very good looking man
masha allah and on top of that he was
actually the servant
of a certain man and a woman
whereas the woman would always be there
with him constantly the same woman
and she actively want to seduce him and
try him and try him over and over and
over and over and over but what did he
say
when she locked him in a room and said
that like this is going to happen you're
not going to say no
what did he
say he said ma'am allah he said i fear
allah and he literally bolted out the
door he ran out the door so i mean
obviously we're not
saying what drake did is good no bro we
don't care about you whenever
anyone else or what they do we're saying
allah we fear allah i fear allah you run
out that door but
the bigger issue as if i had mentioned
is that we live in a society where this
kind of stuff is okay where you have men
and women just
completely free mixing all the time
and because of that you have promiscuity
and because of promiscuity you have high
stds and hiv and all these sexually
transmitted diseases that go about in
society because everyone's sleeping
around different people now on top of
that you have so many hearts getting
broken people don't know what love is
and we've actually developed this this
breakup mentality that when it's not
going my way i will just leave them
break up with them and find someone else
that's the main reason i would say why
marriages don't work because people and
a lot of the time
women they have this mentality that you
know he's not meeting my high
expectations that that and the standards
that society tells me i should have for
myself and for him so i'm gonna leave
him and either be lonely the rest of my
life or find someone else all these
things are huge contributing factors to
horrible diseases we have like high
divorce rates and and and promiscuity
and all that stuff pornography or maybe
i shouldn't say that but um you know
addictions and all right we brought this
rate i'm pretty sure this
yeah
like this done already
no way
stuff cause it got demonetized check
right there support us or wherever it is
right there uh three muslims on patreon
but uh for real content anyway we'll
carry on
yeah so
contributing to all these desire
diseases in society and stuff so what is
the solution
the solution is islam people think that
oh either you're you're you're a liberal
or you're like either you're left-wing
or right-wing
either you're a capitalist or a
communist socialist
people don't know that there's a middle
ground islam and islam has its own
political theory has its own legislative
theory it has its own economic theory
it's on social theory and not these
aren't theories to us are a fact because
they come from allah subhana wa
and
within there we have a society where you
don't have this promiscuity you don't
have
you know gender is just free mixing like
this and in a place where groping uh
takes uh you know takes place and
and sexual assaults take place and all
of these atrocities rape and all that
stuff it's not that they never happen
obviously they do occur and you can
never fully stop it unless you
completely isolate people 100 of the
time
but
it allows for it
on a very minuscule scale
and on top of that the punishment is a
lot more severe so people the men are
less likely to do it and the women in
this case who would commit you know
adultery or whatever sperm theft and all
that stuff would be less likely to do it
because in islamic country the
punishment for
adultery sex outside of marriage whether
you're married or not married
it is severe so a woman would not want
to get pregnant when she's not married
because that would basically be proving
to everyone that she had sex outside of
marriage which would get some kind of
punishment for her so no matter how you
look at it islam would not allow for
such atrocities to exist in the first
place but our society does and that's
something we need to deal with
no before we go into all the the
multiple facets of islam i want to
quickly mention right now to all the
viewers wondering where where's angel
bro where the heck is on her angel is
currently moving and he's moving his
permanent residence
to somewhere that we're not going to
disclose right now obviously because
he's not here i don't want to talk about
that without him here so when he's ready
to come back on the channel we'll talk
about that where he is where he's moving
to uh how long he's going to be there so
on and so forth uh and by the way guys
just a quick disclaimer our live stream
time might change now because of a very
difference in time zone me and ramy are
still you know at the same time
alhamdulillah
um okay before we go on
i want to pre-phase this by saying
continuing off of what you were saying
without me
they don't have the systems in place
here
because they also misunderstand the
systems that we want in place
a lot of men that are supporting drake
in this right they might be a part of
whatever movement that you want to call
it
they might think okay you guys are
talking about marriage cool
but we don't believe we don't want
marriage look at the west look at the
the divorce settlement laws look at you
know the the woman always takes half
regardless of what she did look at all
the the the false rape allegations and
false rape convictions okay look at look
at camel hair is keeping all those men
in in prison knowing that they were
wrongfully convicted this is reality
so why would i want to get in a marriage
with a woman now what if she leaves me
anyway what if this happens
and what they fail to understand is
legally constituted marriage is very
different than a religious constitution
of marriage right i'm not saying you
can't have both which you know you
should have both but they're very
different things
multiple reasons we talked about um you
can check out all of our episodes with
uh brother gabriel or uh sheikh faraz
alhamadi but we're not gonna get too
deep into that right now but multiple
reasons they're completely different and
i know a lot of you are gonna say okay
men are naturally polygamous or some men
naturally want to have multiple women
look at look at what's happening in the
west they're cheating they're doing this
they're having mistresses side things
whatever you call it
but reality is in islam there's a
solution for that we have polygeny now
in islam it's not that we can't have
monogamy you can have monogamy if you
want to but polygamy is always an option
right palladium's premise the ones from
allah this prevents all these things
that are happening like cheating and you
know sleeping around and doing things
under people's noses and all that but
these are just some of the things that i
want to bring up before we go on
yeah so just to kind of piggyback off
that point
i want to mention something for the
sisters as well because yes um as men
we're gonna understand men uh in the
situations they find themselves in like
you know when a man ends up getting ends
up getting divorced despite being you
know the best man he could be uh and
then half his stuff is taken uh and even
if he has a prenup even that's like kind
of fishy business hard to deal with and
all that uh so he his stuff basically he
feels like it's stolen from him and his
wife where his ex-wife now moves on with
another man and and he's heartbroken all
that stuff men do experience that that
pain tremendously and a lot of sisters
feel very similarly when it comes to men
where like for example when you know
both of them get older the men may
actually get more attractive and the
woman gets less attractive and then the
man ends up leaving her uh divorcing her
leaving her with nothing essentially
except the man that she asked for which
maybe it was fifty thousand dollars
maybe he was a kitten
and he ends up marrying someone else so
on and so forth there's many problems uh
in today's society as a whole
surrounding marriage and divorce and all
of that because of the certain uh laws
that we have in place that you know a
woman basically ends up being entitled
to half your stuff well who said that
and that you know it's not mandatory for
a woman to be given a dowry and there's
no such standard for a dowry and when a
woman
you know even ends up being divorced
that the man should at least still take
care of her for a certain amount of time
and he's definitely obligated to take
care of his children and so on and so
forth you find all these issues like you
know women ending up picking and
choosing kind of like i want a man to
you know support me uh and financially
and to make money i don't have to pay
bills i don't have to do anything but
i'm not going to cook i'm not going to
clean i'm not going to be the
traditional wife he's going to be a
traditional man you have them picking
and choosing because it's natural for a
woman to want to be taken care of by men
and that's a beautiful thing we say that
100 women shouldn't have to work if they
want you go for it you start a business
go for it
like allah has given you the right goal
for it but we believe that the men
should be the ones working providing and
that the women just do a lot better of a
job nurturing taking care of children
and and so on and so forth so we think
that this is the best way to live but
since society and people especially on
the legislative level want to ignore
these
these basic differences that we have and
act like everyone's normal and whether
you have uh this genital or that
genitalia or whatever it's it doesn't
make a difference we're honestly out of
whack here to be completely honest
something we need to work on
literally bro
like
one channel or another this this is
reality bro ladies and gentlemen that
whatever rami is saying the reason it's
facts
is i'm not just you know we're not just
giving you reasons and saying you know
believe this it makes sense it's
sensical but if you don't believe us go
go look at what's happening go go the
other way take take do the opposite of
what we're saying we don't advise that
obviously but but do it and and see
where it gets you bro
this is this is the west and marriage
bro i want to add to your point about
marriage marriage isn't something as see
as like big of a deal you know as as in
when i say big of a deal it's so
important but it's not there's no not so
much emphasis it's very normal it's very
simple the problem said the difference
between halal and haram
two witnesses and a wali
simple
simple this is not some big grand
gesture proposal you gotta you know date
for nine years then you gotta you know
vet her and then you still gotta vet her
i'm not saying don't vet her now but
this whole nine ten year thing this bs
that you see and and no one's saying you
know that that you know you should get
into marriages that simply and islam but
i'm saying it's very simple divorce is
permissible there's there's roles and
responsibilities it's very clear cut
there's no you know if she if you know
something happens and you leave that you
have to give her half and then for women
there's no like okay you're gonna have
to be expected to do what a man does
there's none of this it's fair for both
parties it's very natural it's very
normal to our fitrah but what do you
have when you have a society where
marriage is sought out to be some some
weird thing subhanallah bro
all the kofa friends i have from uni
most of them are in in in long-term
relationships with with a girl for like
five plus years but they're still not
married
how does like
i don't blame them bro because they see
marriage to be this huge commitment
where i'm just like bro
i know couples in islam that are married
for like a week or two
and allah might love them more
than people that are just dating or
together for 10 years
because they have the blessing and the
barakah from allah
you know it's not and it's not just i
found it grow and let me just test it
out and and whatever
yeah yeah 100
100 and if you look at islam compared to
the west you'll find so many differences
subhanallah and these differences are
not just like oh we believe this we and
they believe that these differences are
like this is why our societies
were better when we had an islamic
system and all of that this is why the
you know our societies thrive for so
long you know the islamic ummah was
thriving for probably over a thousand
years it's because we had this beautiful
way of life and we look at society
people are wondering what gender they
are people are questioning what they are
even though they were born a very
specific way so look at the west and
let's go to the root of the problem
and first before i do that i want to
point something out that the west will
teach you that there you have one true
love
you have one true love who you will you
should fight through thick and thin to
be with and they're perfect for you and
you're perfect for them and you will
have your happily ever after
and so on and so forth let's let's let's
address that bro this this one is thing
you're talking about this is yeah this
is something i've seen growing up bro
there's only one true love yeah and this
is this is the big uh honestly
lie
a fairy tale like bro you're not
cinderella i'm not prince charming we're
not amazing like uh you know fairies
running around putting magic dresses and
heels on people listen
this is real life this is the real world
in the real world there's no such thing
as the one true perfect only person and
at the same time society's preaching
that they're also preaching that you
should try and test and trial different
people in relationships and if they
don't meet this standard of yours which
is like all the way up here then kick
them to the curb and go to the next
person whether you're a man or a woman
this is exactly so how society teaching
that you have one but also having this
breakup culture and this divorce culture
it's the most atrocious thing ever and
where is this rooted this is rooted in
liberalism and what is liberalism i'm
not just going around calling people
libtards and all that stuff no
liberalism is the belief it's it's it's
a way of life it's a way of thinking
it's it's a principle it's a belief that
i should do whatever brings me pleasure
a lot of the time physical pleasure
physical pleasure
as long as i'm not you know causing any
one harm now there's there's two huge
issues with this one how do you know
that something that's not that that's
pleasuring you in the moment is not
going to hurt you in the long run and
then what you what you have there you
just have a paradox that you maximize
pleasure minimize pain but what if that
pleasure now causes you pain in the
future what kind of paradox is that and
what if what if
uh what seems to harm you now like let's
say that uh you know you've been
drinking and you want to stop drinking
for your long-term health but it
actually causes you some kind of
depression and sadness in the moment
because giving up is a really hard thing
to do when you're addicted well do you
say well no i need that pleasure now
this is short-term gratification versus
long-term gratification and we live in a
society that propagates this belief so
when you have you know millions of
people going around doing what pleases
them physically not putting the greater
good of society as a whole
on the on the top level in terms of
their priority then of course you're
gonna have cases like this of course
you're gonna have people that
they you know they just look to sleep
around like oh i'm going to use you and
get my pleasure from you and then when i
find someone else that i can use and i
don't need you anymore i don't feel like
i need you i will kick you to the [ __ ]
and i will go to that person then do the
same thing to them until eventually it's
done to me and then i do on a larger
scale because i'm even more pissed off
now and it just keeps going until a
person dies
you're right bro her people hurt people
this is this is this is the cycle you
know the abuse becomes the abuser
when are people going to realize that
the systems they have in place the the
standard operating procedure sop that
they're following in the west
man-made
is is not really what's natural for us
it's not from our creator it's not it's
not something that's sustainable there's
no you know
there's no wisdom in it there's no heck
mine it's not from allah it's it's
evident it's self-evident but people
keep thinking okay no maybe it's the one
and i wanna i wanna take this take this
opportunity to just say the media is
extremely responsible for this bro the
media is extremely responsible you have
girls reading these romance novels and
fairy tales having this one guy that
that is clearly not for them but they
think they can change him because she's
so great that she can defy you know male
sexuality or or male proclivities that
you know at the end you know he he turns
into prince charming and he actually
becomes a good guy when he shouldn't
have been someone that she gets with
anyway
and you know we get into this culture
where people are taking things into
their own hands the ego centrism of men
and women today by far
unprecedented levels bro people think
that it's all selfish but i can turn
this person into who i want to turn into
you know i can make this marriage work
we maybe i'm so smart that i don't need
to pray a sahara
i don't need to you know you look get
signs from allah or i don't need to go
to someone else i'm so smart that i know
this person that i see as a potential
candidate i know they're my soul mate i
know i'm going to last with them forever
we're never going to break up we're
going to love each other forever and
nothing's going to happen
then you have stuff where you put so
much emphasis and so much of your
happiness in someone where you don't
look at them as a spouse you look at
them as a part of you and what happens
when someone's a part of you when they
leave and they walk away which is very
natural you know in reality that you
feel like you're missing a part of
yourself you feel like you lost a part
of yourself
but the issue was you let them become a
part of your identity too soon
now this isn't a podcast about love and
wholeness and any of this so we'll spare
you all the emotional stuff but how this
links to this is
all these people that are committing
zina
trying to keep you know finding the one
because because don't don't give me this
this whole you know xena culture and
look at actors look at people that have
made it they can have any girl they want
they can have any man they want yet
they're still married right so everyone
wants companionship everyone wants that
that you know
spouse or spouses if you're a man
but it's like until you find that if you
think you know you're just gonna find
you know success everywhere you go every
person you sleep with you're not gonna
find reality and you're not gonna find
fulfillment that way you think you might
but you're not gonna find it that way um
for all the women that are watching this
that that's what the man and you know
the man is not serious about you and not
committed to you he hasn't come to your
father he's not he's not down to take
you seriously and commit
why are you with him actions speak
louder than words i know i know you
might think you know he says he loves me
though you know he says he'll do this
but he never does
well here's the thing he never does and
for all the men that are with women
that you know she keeps doing things
that that you know crosses the line or
it displeases you and makes you unhappy
and you say oh it was just that one time
or this no bro like except that you
might not be with the right person and
that allah has something better for you
but you might not get that because
you're too scared to hold on to what you
think is right for you
yeah yeah that is very true that is very
true allah he says in the quran
that you may love a thing which is bad
for you and you may hate a thing that is
good for you you don't know and allah
knows
there's your answer right there you
don't know
you feel you think
you desire
but you don't know and that's the
problem you think that your thoughts
are you knowing you think that your
desires are you knowing
those aren't that's not purpose
that's not
fact that's not truth that's not knowing
what's actually best for you that's just
desire
people might desire you know to do drugs
or to drink
is that what's good for them people
might desire to go harm people in
society some people actually do is that
actually something that's good no so
what we desire is not actually what's
always best for us sometimes it is
but this is the key allah tells he says
you have these desires
you have them
you can only fulfill them in a way that
i say is permissible in a way that i say
is best so you have sexual desires you
can only fulfill them through marriage
with a man and a woman the only way it's
allowed
me look at this
addresses bro
the word zina means rape or sexual force
nowhere in the quran is
this
father mandated for our relationship
where is this coming from so you're
telling me that abu bakr didn't give
rasha in marriage you're telling me that
the prophet saw didn't give fatima in
marriage you're telling me that the
prophet saws didn't specifically say
that to have a nikah you need a wali you
need the permission of the wali in the
approval of diwali
and zinna meaning
uh
just
sexual force or rape
how about the woman the woman who went
to the prophet
and said i committed zinna
is she saying that she raped a man
which does happen by the way but we're
just saying statistically yeah and i'm
saying back then
back then they didn't she didn't have a
drug to drug him and make him drowsy
when men were marrying when men were
burying their daughters
yeah like
like where are you getting this from bro
well you're actually you're the one
operating out of off of culture a
liberal culture
you're operating off of a liberal
culture actually uh so you really need
to check that and go ask a scholar
bro it might be a hadith rejected bro
listen so you okay i think they are
hadith rejecter you want the quran i'll
give you the quran
allah says in the quran
that
this we have revealed this book we have
revealed the quran so that you the
prophet can explain it to them allah he
also says in the quran that they will
never be true believers they will never
fully believe until they make you the
prophet
a judge between them in all their
affairs all their disputes
and
find no discomfort in their heart when
you give a ruling
and submit with full submission
the only way you do that today is with
the hadith of the prophet peace be upon
him and what does he say he teaches us
exactly what the net is
and the punishment for zina as is
mentioned in the quran he teaches us
what nikah is and the conditions for
nikah as mentioned by the father from
the hadith and if you
reject it
then honestly like you have to honestly
you're not muslim to be completely
honest because you're going against the
quran here at this moment
in the legal jurisprudence of islam
authentic hadith hold the same
equivalent legislative authority as any
ayah from the quran
any ayah from the quran this is facts
nor am i saying they're it's you know
they're they're equal in terms of of uh
you know who it's from no one from allah
wants you know
narration from that is prophesy
but in terms of islam they're just as
authoritative in the court
yeah yeah
yeah bro
anyway did we cover most of the points
that were on your mind in terms of this
whole drake issue
how islam is is literally the antidote
to all of this fashion that's going on
yeah yeah i think we did i just want to
mention something in the beginning there
were a lot of people who were kind of
questioning you know
why are you talking about this thought
of the islamic podcast and all that and
these same people may allah bless them
may allah these same people took
complete 180 and they're not agreeing
with us and back to like you know
whatever they were saying before
uh just guys you know
assume the best
always assume the best and look for the
best
and don't be so quick to jump to
conclusions because this is another uh
concept that we have in our society this
cancel culture and this whole like you
know i i
got a little waff a little scent of
something i don't like let me completely
condemn this person just be more careful
insha'allah
other than that i think everything
has been said
all right so anyone has any questions
any any inquiries we got about 20-ish
minutes left
so we're going to address these
questions and then we got jamaa
yes
bro what time is jamaat today
1 30.
1 30 100
145 for us
cutting it close man
i couldn't believe my eyes when i read
the title yeah that's that's that's what
that's what it is that's that's what
it's come to bro or is this or you know
this is this is what it is
i'm i'm i'm surprised because when i
read it i found out on twitter bro i
don't know about you but when i found
out i was like bro this has to be one of
those jokes bro or like just you know
like a like a fake accusation or
something like that but yeah yeah it's
crazy man yes
okay sister bushreds what are the
advantages and disadvantages of
pollution okay so
first thing let me pin that up right
there um
i want to get this off before you know
me let me know if i missed anything
right so the main advantage of polygyny
main event and there's and when i say
main i'm just you know from me there's
there's no you know there's not no
hierarchy right so from all the
advantages of religion for anyone
watching what is politician even right
because we gotta address this first
there's polygamy and polygyny polygamy
with an m at the end instead of an n is
just
sleeping with multiple people having
you know relations with multiple people
having intercourse with multiple people
or marrying multiple people whatever you
want to call it it's just a person with
multiple people
um or it could be multiple people with
multiple people that's like polyamory
and all this we're not getting into this
polygyny with an n is one man having
multiple women okay
we're not introducing islam yet right
this is just that the word
linguistically what polygyny means one
man with multiple women
the advantages of
polygyny if done right in islam which is
one man with a ma with a maximum of four
women
all of those women get security
so
in the traditional monotheistic not not
monotheistic what am i saying monogamy
um because we're still monotheistic
monogamy which is in the kofar and you
know it's it's a very new phenomenon
right it's a very selfish thing too
if you want to enforce it when you have
monogamy you're guaranteeing that one
woman has provisioning you are
guaranteeing alhamdulillah there's
nothing wrong with that when you have
polygamy you're guaranteeing up to four
women have provisioning from that one
man
okay if done correctly
another benefit is men are naturally
polygamous men have natural polygamous
tendencies nowhere am i saying men can't
do monogamy men can of course do
monogamy but when men have this natural
proclivity this higher testosterone this
higher sex drive and they have you know
a natural tendency to want variety and
more you know outlets and i'm just
saying it as it is because no other
channel will say it like this but when
men want that
and you expect them to be monogamous
it's going against our fitra guys it's
going against our nature you denying
polygamy as you denying islam or sorry
polygeny is denying islam because allah
has made it permissible for us
it is the sunnah so when you look at you
know polygyny it allows men a healthy
uh way of practicing this sexual
inclination without cheating adultery
fornication zina all of this fascia
furthermore an advantage of polygyny
is you still guarantee
lineage your heredity your
paternity right so when you look at
polyandry and a lot of women will say
why can't women have four husbands right
let's say let's assume a woman has four
husbands all right
she has four husbands
um which is very smart by the way
because once she gets pregnant she's out
of commission for nine months so very
smart
in nine months she has a kid she doesn't
know who's who's the father she doesn't
know so
there's scientific primary peer reviewed
literature to show that kids that grow
up without assurance of paternity as in
knowing who their father is
more likely to get into a lot of
societal diseases we'll leave it at that
but the kid doesn't know because how
will how will they and their mother
doesn't even know because the mother had
four partners now i know today in the
modern world we have paternity because
that's besides the point that's not what
i'm talking about
a woman
when she gives birth to a kid son or
daughter she knows a hundred percent
that's her kid there's no doubt in her
mind that that's her kid
right because it literally came out of
her
a man
can never get that guarantee
i know if a man even if a man has a wife
and it's like
monogamy you know just one man and one
woman
he never has that assurance of paternity
the same way that she has the guarantee
of maternity because she knows the baby
came out of her he doesn't know if
that's his it could be but now when you
add three more men into that mix
it's a 25 chance at most that it is
right
so that's one point that's one
disadvantage of of uh polyandry and one
advantage of polygamy
polygyny offers the same assurance of
paternity that monogamy does it's still
100 because when you have one man and
multiple women
all the women know it's hers because it
came out of them and the man knows it is
because he's the only man right if done
properly
if no cheating and all this hospital
switching and all this stuff that goes
on so that's one advantage can you think
of any other advantages that i might
have missed aside from this
um
no i would just kind of like go over
what you mentioned if you don't have
anything more to add
okay
i just kind of want to reiterate some
things you mentioned but if you have
more to add i'll wait till you're done i
don't i really don't think there's much
more things i could think of um for
advantages of that um and also it gives
women
that uh
might not find partners
and might not have an easy time finding
partners
um a partner
yeah it gives everyone a companionship
at the end of the day but yeah yeah 100
yeah and we can always we can talk about
the uh the wisdoms behind it
okay so it's always tuning in every week
may allah bless you for blessing us
so you can you can look at the wisdoms
forever you can even argue that like you
know uh there would be less divorced
women because if a man can marry four
wives then he'd be more likely to marry
at least one divorcee or one widow or
you know whereas if he was married one
woman he's less likely to marry a
divorced woman a widowed woman woman and
all that
um so on and so forth so you can argue
all these things but essentially
when we say polygyny we're talking about
again what islam what it is islamically
entails meaning that
a man he pays maher four times the four
different women
he takes care of four different women he
houses four different women and the
children and the kids so there's more
halal less haram more muslim children
and less children born out of wedlock
and so on and so forth so any blessing
that you could see in monogamy one
marriage and you could say that times
four
and a month this is this is not four
girlfriends like you're saying not four
side chicks four women you take
responsibility and accountability for
from who in the eyes of allah first and
foremost
and in islamic country
under the sharia law as well
because here you can promise a woman
that you'll pay her a 50k maher and then
just never do it and be held accountable
by allah and in islamic country they
will make sure you pay that
that under allah you are that's like a
legal obligation upon you now because
you said you would do that and you
signed off on it and everything
100 100
all right
now
disadvantages of pollution wow this is a
very this is a loaded question so i'm
trying to think bro let me know if you
can think of any the only disadvantage i
could think of polygyny
is
when it's not done right i was going to
say the same exact thing yeah because
you see a lot of things where men are
favoring one wife over another wife and
they're giving one wife more rights
pause that ain't islam so i don't that
shouldn't happen in the first place
that's like saying oh what if i marry
someone and he turns out to be an
alcoholic therefore marriage is bad it's
the same reasoning
marriage is not bad you're you're you're
equivocating two things that are that
are not
the premises are not related whatsoever
with one another so you cannot say that
oh
i mean i did polygyny or my mom did
pelignie and i saw what it did to her
the the look on her eyes when when my
dad stayed with the other woman
five times a week and gave her more love
and time and all that's not pollution my
friend that's not pollution done
properly the islamic way
so that's one issue another issue is
when uh
you know so the first one was a man
gives more rights to one wife than the
other other wives um whether it be
equality or equity that is not islamic
whatsoever all right can you think of
any other ways that people might misuse
or not do collision correctly bro
yeah um i think that's basically it
because we can't even as muslims we
can't even try and argue that pelogeny
is bad or has disadvantages in any way
to be honest um like imagine arguing
anything else was like has disadvantages
like salah has disadvantage can you
imagine someone claiming that like it's
not it doesn't have any disadvantages
unless you as a person believe it's
wrong
and it gives you cognitive dissonance
which is what people are taught nowadays
that's wrong or if you're not doing it
right as brother fayette said other than
that there's no problems thanks sister
bush i just want to say jazakallahu for
your amazing questions you know you gave
one amazing question we're going to
answer the second one too and to anyone
watching that there's a ton of comments
on the side we're using stream yet so if
we don't address your questions because
it's just the sheer number of questions
that we're having if you do want to
guarantee your answer is your question
is answered send a super chat so i get a
notification at the top and i can easily
click it and then i'll pin the message
and we'll answer it inshaallah that
being said sister bush writes as a young
adult i don't understand why society has
such a bad mindset to man or men who
choose pelogeny even if done right can
you explain so the first thing i want to
say is this is when you talk about
society you're talking about culture and
cultural norms and the ways of the land
and not allah because nowhere in islam
is polygamy something to be shy of or to
move away from when you look at culture
this is a very post-modern culture of
monogamy monogamy was not a thing even
even 200 years ago a year 100 years ago
look at the kings look at the
archbishops look at all the rulers of
europe and all of this this is this is
not something that's as natural polygyny
was natural so at that time when you
bring something like
you know polygyny with even four as a
cap that's weird because men were having
hundreds of women men were having no
limit on women so even when you went
from that to polygamy with four that's
weird that's like that's not that's not
with the times now fast forward we're
moving to a time where monogamy is the
norm so polygyny with even two would be
you know it's weird what are you doing
bro why do you need two women do you not
love her
this is this is another thing we can get
into in another episode that has nothing
to do with love at least you know for
men
um yeah so
it's culture
culture they they equivocate this they
have bad you know experiences with this
there's a taboo in in the muslim culture
not with islam with intimacy even
we're just talking about sex and talking
about these things with your kids and
you look at the prophet saws he was not
shy about these you know any topics with
with kids and and the youth and in the
masajid talking to them and and giving
lectures about this none of the sahaba
radhila
were shy about these things you know
intimacy is something that i think is is
something to not shy away from so that
you can maintain you know our our
islamic you know the ummah and propagate
it
but there's so many taboo things that
shy about this they don't like to talk
about you know polygyny and and intimacy
and all this so allah
yeah yeah yeah very true
um
and i mean
with anything we have we have to ask
where did it come from this monogamy
thing where did it come from we actually
got it from the romans uh
who were non-muslims
who have committed many atrocities so on
and so forth so
you would have to ask the question that
why is monogamy the only thing that's
good
and why is polygamy something that's
actually bad because everyone like it's
a word taught in society that it's wrong
that it's bad but the truth is no one
can actually prove that the reason they
think it's wrong or bad is because
they've already decided that it's not
our way and anything that's not our way
is automatically bad it's honestly the
same line of thinking as like as like
tribalism racism it's not if it's not
from amongst us then it's it's it's not
allowed
if you're not liberal it's not allowed
if it's not democratic it's not allowed
that's exactly how the west has been
for decades now maybe
over a century
and i believe catholicism like
modern-day mainstream christianity is
monogamy
yeah you know and and someone has to
factor me on this too but you're not
allowed to do divorce in christianity
too until death do your part so i don't
know
a lot of things in christianity they're
not normal you know this episode's not
on christianity but what we're trying to
say uh sorry i don't mean normal i mean
natural right in islam everything is
natural all these laws they already
resonate within us they already make
sense intuitively right for men having
multiple women permissibly in a proper
righteous way um for divorce
for you know providing for women men
naturally want to provide for women this
is another thing too
men don't want you know a woman
providing for them women want a man
providing for them but men naturally
have this proclivity to provide for a
family to provide for those that he's
provisioning for and to feel respected
for that right it's not the other way
around now this is not saying a woman
can't work or can't provide for her
family you know if she wants to
but the obligation is not there that's
what i'm trying to say
okay
how to marry multiple women any advice
the only advice i'll give you is if you
can't even have success with one woman
and run a marriage properly with her
don't even think of multiple women
yeah
yeah
listen the only advice
is what allah says
he says mary two three or four but if
you cannot be just and fair between the
maryland one
make sure you're ready basically
i just want to say um by the way he's
talking about this comment how to marry
multiple women right so shaq writes uh
you know get loads of money i just want
to say that you can have all the money
in the world
but you're not going to have a righteous
wife necessarily unless allah wills that
for you
so this is something we talk about in
the episode we have with ali dawa so
check that out i'll just search up the
three muslims on youtube and see that
episode it's a very good episode for
anyone that's currently trying to get
married or they have marriage on their
mind or they just can't find marriage or
religion or anything
when you have allah's blessing when
you're fixing your affairs and allah has
you know a wife or wives ready for you
that's when you get them it's not having
loads of money no i'm not gonna lie and
say money doesn't help of course
money helps even with monogamy even
finding the best partner that you can
get money will help you for dunya
worldly things but we as muslims we
don't
we don't believe that money takes
precedence over allah whatsoever we
don't you know in the dunya money can
get you a lot of things you want to buy
a car you want to do this of course when
it comes to marriage and finding a
righteous spouse that allah has for you
the only thing that can get you that is
allah there's no money there's no you
know status oh i need a good job and i
know this is this is a hard pill to
swallow because people coming from you
know the south asian and maybe the other
communities where the parents are saying
you know how are you going to find a
wife you're not a doctor yet you're not
a lawyer i know it sounds a little crazy
i know people that they've just
graduated university at 18
they've gotten a spouse before going to
uni they're still with them 10 plus
years and now they're still together and
they're really happy
i know people that are doctors that have
300 400 500k income
and they're still not married bro this
is not married
in my own family like this is not a
surprise bro money doesn't bring you a
spouse
you know
money can bring you women
but money doesn't necessarily bring you
a wife
yeah
yeah and i also want to mention the flip
side with money that with more money you
have you have more of a chance of that
money being spent or earned incorrectly
and that opens a whole other realm of of
worries
uh because they're when we look at life
we don't just have men and women in
marriage and like there's there's
there's so much more to life than just
you know married and intergender
relationships and all that
let's say you have billions of dollars
bro you honestly i wouldn't even be
worried about marriage i'd be worried
about how the billions of dollars are
being spent if i'm giving in charity if
i'm actually helping the ummah with this
money because to be completely honest we
we praise relationships too much we
praise marriage too much
it honestly it didn't seem
like the constitution of marriage is
very important islamically
but it's not it should not be put to a
level where it's like it's all that
matters to us there are some scholars
that dedicate their life to islam and
either decided they're not going to get
married or forgot to get married imam
and now we recommend he was passing away
they asked why didn't he get married he
said i forgot because he was so focused
on the dean of allah imam
and he asked when he was asked why don't
you get married he said don't waste my
time with that like i have the dean of
allah to focus on and look at what he
ended up producing so first and foremost
be on like this level where
any money you have you're spending in
the way of allah and you're focused on
earning it in a way in a way allah
says permissible and spending in a way
that he thinks is best and then worry
about you know other things in dunya
matters and everything
rami bro i got a physics question from
you because my boy angel is not here
today so if we got 113 viewers on the
live stream right now how many likes
should we have
um 113
yeah
okay let me just calculate it man sorry
i have my calculator here
okay now we have 116.
how many elections we have 113 plus 3
times 0.8
uh syntax error um about 600 600 okay
you heard of your first bro um your
range of error is also probably zero
right so it's like this is a this is the
correct answer like objectively 600
likes minimum we should have on this
video guys so what are you doing smash
the like button and before we end up the
stream i just want to say one thing
we're not seeing live broke we're not
saying don't make money we want you to
make money matter of fact money will get
you farther in this dunya
in terms of living and then being
shackled to the system then not having
money it will give you capability it
will give you freedom it will give you a
right to do what you want to do right
and not just you know oh should i should
i work at this haram place for a lot of
money or do halal for little money no
money will prevent all of this
what we're saying is the way that you
guys are looking at money is not the way
that i want you to look at money don't
look at money as as a means to
get farther in terms of uh you know
worldly affairs if you don't have allah
in the picture already allah has to be
in the picture
once that's in place okay yeah then then
worry about money worry about allah
focus on allah pleasing allah money will
come naturally and i'm a testament to
this bro rami i don't know about you but
i experienced this firsthand when i'm
chasing money and i'm chasing the dunya
it's an uphill battle bro but when i'm
chasing allah and pleasing allah the
dunyas at my feet bro
yeah 100 i think there's actually hadith
that says that
i agree so if you guys want to you know
you know go more into that check out our
episode we're going to do with musa
adnan our brother musan it's going to
air this weekend on sunday y'all better
watch it smash the heck out of the like
button on that video share tell your
friends this is i'll say this rami this
to me and this is also what brother musa
then sent me a voice memo today on we
both agree that this is the best episode
that we've ever
you know listened to or been in like one
of the best like this was insane bro
what about you
yeah 100 percent definitely definitely
one of the best masha'allah
100 100
all right guys we got two minutes left
any other last minute questions let us
know if not so we are going to end the
stream
okay is there any ruling in islam that
says the most have kids i don't i don't
think so
not that i can think of there's no
ruling in attempt to even get married to
begin with
it's just heavily encouraged the fossils
sent him he said don't say don't say
that you will not get married like don't
say i'm not getting married
but it's not uh as far as i know
when's the tour to uk
ah
man when when this whole
craziness that's happening in the world
ends or at least alleviates because
right now in canada things are not
looking good
then we can leave and we'll definitely
visit the uk inshallah
inshallah okay next question where in
canada are you guys
in
ontario
ontario there we go
okay big man writes money is so
important but it should never be a
priority over 100 percent 100 look at
the sahaba radha
people had money
the the greats um the greatest
companions the greatest muslims they we
had money they we were not poor i'm not
saying norman saying being poor but they
had achara first they prioritized akhra
over everything else
and today we have this opposite thing
where it's like people are chasing money
but it's like at the expense you know
like oh i have important client calls
i'm gonna get all of them but i'm not
gonna pray until at the end and now i
have four prayers to make up that's not
that's not the way
you know make time for allah and just
watch just watch how you'll exceed in
this dunya
yeah
inshallah one day man it's gonna be
interesting it's gonna be good where's
the third brother uh we mentioned at the
end at the beginning of the stream he is
traveling at the moment
bro don't don't get me started i believe
someone did a comparative assay a
mathematician about the the wealth that
ultimately
had and it was somewhere along i believe
100 billion or like just billions like i
don't even want to get into that but
just building just
numerous just just financial freedom you
know and that's the level you want to
get to when you want to do something
like build a mosque or stuff like that
there's no crowdfunding or can you guys
you know help me out with this
you are the source you are the money you
go around like you know you're
self-sufficient there's no asking people
no handouts none of this and that's the
thing even if you want to be
an imam today
if you want to be a chef today
i'm not i'm not putting shade on anyone
on this when i say this but to some
extent if you want to belong to an
organized
i guess affiliate you know affiliated
with an organization you somewhat have
to say stuff that they want you to say
and you can't talk too much about things
you know they don't want you to talk
about
one of my friends he's a shack and he
was uh he was an imam at different
masjids in uh the uae
for you know a lot of numerous years ten
plus years and bro they were literally
giving them a script
like forget saying what you want to say
to uh to you know
on your own thing he had a script he
couldn't even say what he wanted to say
so this is what i'm talking about this
is the reality of of you know today
having money gives you freedom to do
what you want when you want and if you
have akra in your hands already
and you're pleasing a lot then game over
like what can you not do with money
okay last minute
will you make an episode with brother
hijab hi anyone watching this episode
that's made it this far i want you to go
to muhammad's channel i want you to grow
his most recent video whatever it is i
haven't checked in a while and just just
spam the comments and i'm just playing
don't spam the comments one comment per
person uh just just write to get on the
three muslims podcast you know just just
just go over there hit him up or go on
instagram find muhammad jim go on his
latest post and just just write that in
the comments we gotta get muhammad hijab
on the podcast we got everyone else on
we gotta get muhammad to job on the
podcast bro
inshallah mufti mink as well uh noman
ali khan is there anyone else that comes
to mind bro for you
um
not that i can think of now to be honest
okay
all right uh last question you still
going gym bro i'm doing homeworkouts man
gyms are closed everything is locked
down
yeah
i don't mean what about you
yeah same thing same thing
mma is close too so
yeah it's kind of tough bro just
bodyweight only i know
yeah all right and y'all should give
street though a try ramy do you want to
talk about that
yeah inshallah i i agree we should i
mean angel you know he would have to do
it himself in thailand unfortunately but
i do believe we should i know some
brothers are already making initiative
like in toronto and stuff uh so
insha'allah in the areas that we live in
i think we should inshaallah definitely
give it a try maybe once it's more it's
warm so you know the people we're
discussing with don't feel like they
have to run away to get you know into a
warm place
all right that being said it's friday
what's friday it's juma day
your friendly reminder that if you're a
man
and you are muslim
and you are trying to better you're
trying to better your your deen
and your closest to allah go to jama
it's obligatory what are you doing
there's no optional it's not it's not
recommended it's not it's not something
that's you know just you should do it
like like for women um well that's a
different story it's optional for women
for men it's mandatory it's obligatory
go to jama make it happen
and
don't use hot sauce guys don't use hot
sauce
with that being said
uh no there is no episode with daniel
there's two episodes with daniel
that we dropped a few months ago so
check that out if you haven't smash the
like button salaam alaikum